G
TO AA WORK OF SCICE FTION.
THE MAN HIELF,LSO A MICAL
DOOR, NTUCKY SENATORAND
PAUL
A RT Y HAVE BEEN RIGHTBOUT
TH GUYROMHEEGINNING.I WILL  HON.
IRIEDO GIVE H THEENEFIT
THE TOPIC TRE WERE A LOT OTHINT
ONG AT THE BEGNING
I VER THOUGHT ITAS IHE
VARIS.
WE N KNOW O JANRY 3t
AT D FAUCI WAS TOLDTOOKS
LIKEAIN OF FUNCTN MAN
ABTION OF THIS VUS.
THE GENOGRAM -ENOM OF THIS
BY RESCT TT HAPPENS TOE
THE DATHAT DONALD TMP PNPLACE AS
AFTETHE FIRST IDEIFIED CASE
IN THIS COUNY.
YOUAVE BEEN WRI THE WHOLETIME,.
UNFOUNATELY, YOU HE BE
RIGHT.
>>HERE BEEN NO MORE
PROMINT SCNTISTS IN FAVOR OF
GAIN OF FUNION REARCH THANDRFAU.
HE STILL HAS NOTACKED OFF OF
THAT POSITN.
HE BELIEVE THA IT IS OY TO
TA ANIL VIRUSES MAK THEM
TO SUPER VUSES TO INFECT
HUMANSVEN  A PDEMIC SHOULD
OCCU
IT.SAYTHATESEARCH IS WORTH
THE'S AOST OF OER
SCNTISTSN THIS FIELDND
EYAY IT IS NOT WTH IT AT
HAVE NOT ARNE ANYTHING.ALL WE .
EN AER ALL OF TS EVIDENCE
POINTS TOWAR THEUHAN LAB,
THISAST WEEK, AND COMMITT,
DRFAUCIAID, THATE STI
TRTS THE CHINESECIENSTS.
AND E THING ISHAT I A VERY
NÏVE NOTION.
THAT IS W WE GOT HERE.
PUBLIC LOC ARMORSIRUS.THIS IS B.
ABT A 1% MTALI BUT THEYHAVE BEEE
RUSETHAT HAVE 15% MORTALI.
THAT WILL BE 5MILLN DEATHS
GHT W BUT THIS ND ORESEARCHEEDSD
THE.S. TAXPAYER.
I HAVE ANMENDNT THAT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLSAYI NO MOR FUNDS
TO THIS WUHAN LA
WEILLEE WHAT DR.AUCI HASTO SAY.
DOES NOT REALLY HE TO
JUDGNT TO BE IN T POSION
HE IS IN.
ean:ENATOR, I MET THE
MOY THAT HE ISAYIN WASAR
MUCHORE IN TERMSF THE ACTUAL
WEAVE Y IDEA HOWUCH MONEY
ERICAN TAXPAYEONEY WENT TO
FUND THI WIL HN VIROLY --
WUHAN VIROGYAB A THEIR
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESRCH?
>> THERE A L OF TOOLS OF
MONETHERE'S A GROUP.
HE HAS100 MILLION.
NOALL OF THIS H GONE TO00
THEY SAYOR MILITANT M HAV
THE'S LOT OF MEY.
THERE'S DEFSE MONEY.TTHERE'S A .
BUT TH RESRCH IS BN DON
THENITED STAS AS WELL.
IT IS VERY,ERY DANGEUS.
PARTISAN TO MEO WASNGTON.
I SENA LETTER TAY T THE
AD TSAY THAT WEEEDO HAVE
SCIENTISTSHOELIEVE THAT IT
IS INCREDIBLY DANROUS.
THE OTHER DANGERS I HE HFIVE THG
OUTSPON ON IT
ION'TNOW WHAT THE WLD I
COMING TO.
YOU CAN' ASK HONES DIFCULT
IT TURNS OUTHAT DR. FAUCI HNOT S
RESULT, MY FAMY FED THRTS.
>> Sean:'M SRYO HEAR
IT HAS HAPPENETO M
IT HAS BEEN HAPNING TOANY
OTHER PEOPLEN T PUBLIC EYE.
IT GETS' SRY AT TIMES B I
HOPE Y ARE GETTI THEROPER
CURI AND I HOPE OUR
GOVERNNT IPROTECTING A
ELECD OFFICIAL.
LET MESK Y THI
DID DR. FAUCI E BEFORE YOUR
COMMTEE?
HE STILLAYS NO MIQUEENT
FOR GAINF FUNCTIO RESRCH.
ONEF THE PAPER HE NT THE
MAIL THAT HAVE COME INHE LABELS.
AT WAS AT E WAN ITITUTE.
E DTOR THANKED DR. FAUCI
OF NIH.SHE LTS T SERIALUMBEFOR
THEONEY SHE GOT FMHAT.S.
SO HE NDSO BE ASK
WE ND TO HE OTHER SCIENSTS
HEIDES BEHIND TH VEI OF I'M
THE ONLY SMART PERSONN THE
ROOM.
NO ONE ELSEAN UNDERSTAN THI
BUT MANYTHERhD SENTISTS
IN TS FIELD COMETELY
DIGREED WITH HIAND N'T
THINKT IWORTHISKING A
PANDEMIC.
>>ean: SENOR.
>> D I DON'T SEENY BEFITS
OF IT THER
>> Sean: IHINK RECALL AGUNMAN BR
STONE WAS- GENTLEMEN THE
ME OF ROGESTON WAS KNOWN
LYING T CONESS.
HAVE IMPVED CLIENT REPT AT
THISOCATION AT THI TEND
AT IS THE WAY  USULY WAS
HALE.
BU HE H ALMT 30 GUYS IN
TACTICAL GR, TTMAN AND FAKE
NEWS CNNAMER, GUN DWN.
LYINGO CONGRESS.
IS TT A CME?
>> IT SOLUTELY IS ARIME
IT IPUNISHABLE UPO FI
YES IN PRISON
DR. FAUCIS GNG TOORK
AROU HIS WORDS.
IT SOUNDED LIKHEAS SING NOMONEY.
WAS -- N MONEY WENT TO THE
HAN INCIDENT.
HEASEING MORE PRISEN
YING NO GAIN OFUNCON MONEYWENT.
THINK THAT I FALLS ALSO.
IT WIL COME DOWN TON OPION.
HE IS GOING TOAYT WAS NOTN
OF FUNION.
MANY SCIENSTS HAVE BEENAYIN
TH IT ALL WAS GOING OF
NCTION BUT HES NOT BEI
TRHFUL
HES N BEEN COMPLETY
FORTHCING.
HE IA SHADING THAT MEANG OTRUTH.
>> Sean: REAL PRLEM.
EXACY.
ONE OTHER EXAMP I WANT TO
BRING UP.GHT W, INDIA IS SUGGLIG
UNDER IS.
THEYAVE A BILLI PEOE.
30000 OPLE THERE GETNG I
AND EY ARE HAVINBOUT,000
DEATHS.
DRFAUCI REFUSINGO TL
PEOP THA YOUET IMMUNITY
AFTER YOU HAVE THE DISSE.
TH WOULD ALLOW T VCINEN
DIAO BE TARGETO THOSE
WHHAVE NOT BEEN SIC
BUT CAUSDR. FAUCI SAYEVERYONES D
ERYONE SHOULD T THE VACCINE
WITHOUT TNKIN ABOUT IT,
THERE'S T ENGH VACCINE TO GO
AROUND IN IIA P THEIR
PROUND PUBC HEALTH
INVOCATIONOF DR. FAUCIENYING
NARAL NEW DEPICTN DOG SO,
I THINK IT I LEADING TO GREATDEA
THE FIRST SENAR TO GOUBLIANSAYOD
COVI
YO HAVE NATURAL IUNITY.
YOU MADE THE CHOICE AS YOUOWN
DOCTOR NOT TGET E VCINE.
BU I THINK PPLE NEE TO PAYVERY .
EVEN TRAPEICS THAT WE
ADVISED TO DR. FAUCI, HE IGNORED